Russia has officially joined the war in
Syria and I mean who hasn't at this
point russia says its Air Force is
helping the Syrian government fight
against Isis and quote other terrorists
except it seems many of those so-called
terrorists are actually rebels fighting
against the government of Bashar
al-assad including some rebel groups
backed by the United States it's a mess
and I don't blame you for being lost see
Russia and Assad are longtime allies
Syria buys weapons from Russia and
Russia has a naval base there so
Russia's involvement might not really be
about defeating Isis as much as it is
about keeping Assad in power that's what
the United States and its allies are
concerned about they believe Assad
should eventually step down but their
main priority has been fighting Isis the
whole situation is suddenly more
volatile Gulf states which have backed
the rebels with money and weapons are
now promising more and with Russian
planes over Syria and Turkey hopes of a
no-fly zone are slim but could Russia's
direct intervention end the stalemate in
Syria well considering you already got a
dictator killing his own citizens
sectarian militias Kurdish fighters
us-backed rebels Gulf money Israeli
warplanes and on top of that Isis all
with different goals it's hard to see
how more missiles will help but what is
clear is that those who will pay the
biggest price are Syrians themselves
four million of whom have already fled
the country Russia's up the ante but to
what end and our hopes for negotiating a
way out even further out of reach why
isn't anyone doing anything to stop the
war in Syria well maybe because so many
countries are involved in the fighting
let's start on the ground